mark Walton here with a gamespot news
update and more trouble ahead for goddes
developer 22cans as GameSpot has learned
that several key developers have been
asked to leave the studio what others
have resigned the UK based developer
recently came under fire off the back of
accusations that it's failed to deliver
on goddesses promised Kickstarter
rewards well-known producer Gemma Harris
as well as other talent has been moved
onto the studio's next project called
the trial gamespot sources suggest that
there's a link to the recent staff
changes while another with intimate
knowledge of the goddess project has
described it as a failure and adds the
suffice to say the goddess Kickstarter
would not be fulfilled and the team have
either quit their jobs or been moved on
to a new project hard times indeed
gamespot spoke to 22cans co-founder
Peter Molyneux who insisted that the
departures do not spell doom for goddess
and that some of the original
Kickstarter pledges will still be met he
added however that some previously
promised features might not materialize
speaking about the recent staff
departures Molyneux said as always
happens in development when you finish
something and start something new then
you very often refresh your team
sometimes you do that by asking some of
them to leave and sometimes people on
the team want to look elsewhere Molyneux
added that while he claims new staff
will be introduced to support the
struggling projects that are regrets
over how the whole thing has been
managed I take the point that some of
the pledges should have been met and
that we should have taken the time to
work on them I would never do
Kickstarter again in the same way that
we did it doing Kickstarter at the very
start of a game can be very challenging
when the proposed multiplayer mode for
goddess will arrive and when new
recruits will join the studio to help on
the project remains unclear have you
been burned by failed Kickstarter
projects in the past are you still
excited for goddess let us know in the
comments below and for all the latest
gaming news keep it gamespot
you